Let's take a look at the conference API class.
This class defines the API that are exposed through endpoints.
See this API annotation right here? This is what indicates
it. This class contains functions to be exposed through endpoints.
There are rules around how you can name the
API and one of the rules is that the API
name must start with a lowercase letter. So far this
class contains a few methods. The one that we're going to
be looking at in this lesson is save profile.
Let's take a look at it. Here's the Save
Profile Method. You can see up here that we've
defined the @Api Method which indicates that this method
is going to be exposed through end points. So
let's look in to the saved profile method. You
see it defines a bunch of fields user ID,
main email, display name, t-shirt size. For the display
name and the t-shirt size we've set some default values.
And when you're working with your code you can change
these default values as you like. You'll see that the
code contains a bunch of to do's. You're going to be filling
in these to do's, and the numbers indicate the order
in which to do them. So obviously, you do to do
one before you do to do two. So the other
thing that this method does is it creates a new profile
object, passing in the user ID, the
display name, main email, the t-shirt size. And
then it returns a profile. So at this point, it doesn't really do a whole lot
except create and return a Profile object. So let's take a quick look at the
Profile class. Here's the Profile class in an
editor. And not surprisingly, it takes displayName, mainEmail,
teeShirtSize. These are the fields that get passed
in to it. When it's constructed and the
constructor just takes the values that are passed
in and puts them into appropriate fields. The class
also contains getter methods for these fields, it
doesn't contain setter methods, because we only want the
values to be set at construction time. So
now let's run the app and see what happens.
So, we're going to deploy to local host. Okay
and while the deployment is going on, you'll see a
bunch of messages. And at the end you should see
this INFO: Dev App Server is now running. So, now
let's go to the browser and see what we can
see. So we want to look at the app in
the APIs explorer. So you go to the local host
colon, what ever your port number is, in my case
is 8080 and then is _ah/api/explorer. And then,
you see the API explorer, and you see the
conference API, so we can drill down into
it, couple methods. We haven't done anything with the
other method. We'll just look at save profile.
Let's see what happens if we execute save profile
function. Just go ahead and execute it. And
we didn't provide any input parameters so we just
go the default response. So, which is a profile object containing the display
name, that the default that we set and the t-shirt size. Doesn't know what
the t-shirt size is yet because you haven't told it. So go ahead
and post a video if you like and try this out for yourself now.